I don't think anyone is unaware of the
grotesque and the growing gap between
those who own huge wealth and those who
live in poverty what I find frustrating
and very odd is that although we have
identified the fact that the richest 1%
own half the world's wealth and we have
identified the fact that 3.5 billion
people have assets of less than $10,000
we do not identify a further crucial
identifier which is that the richest
people in the world are men and the
poorest are women now that last report
came out in November last year there was
another report that came out in November
last year by the World Bank and UN women
and that had analyzed household survey
data for 89 countries by sex by age by
household composition and other
variables
and again it found that more women than
men live in poverty
it found that households with children
were among the poorest and that single
parents with children and predominantly
single mothers with children which are
the vast majority of single parents
faced a far higher risk of poverty so UN
Women stated that the policy
implications of its findings are very
clear that eradicating poverty was going
to require greater attention to the
vulnerabilities faced by women during
specific periods of their lives the
United Nations sustainable development
goal number one is ending poverty gender
equality is goal number five meanwhile
here in Britain a new report last week
identified that 14 million people are
now living in poverty that includes 4.5
million UK children
the survey was described in one
newspaper as the most sophisticated
analysis yet of material disadvantage in
the UK the most significant innovation
being to build core living costs such as
childcare into its poverty measure the
survey found that poverty is especially
prevalent in families with at least one
disabled person households where no one
works or that are dependent on income
for income on irregular or 0s jobs and
in single-parent families now this study
comes 10 years after austerity was first
introduced it comes one year after
research by the House of Commons library
showed that women were bearing 86% of
the austerity burden that study showed
that in cutting Social Security on which
women disproportionately rely because of
the societal pressures that push more
women than men into unpaid care rules in
addition with cutting investment in care
on which women disproportionately rely
for the same reason the government had
essentially funded its austerity program
by taking money out of poor women's
purses to create tax breaks for the rich
and the rich as we know are
disproportionately men so two things are
clear to me the first is that an
economic model that recognizes the lived
experience of women would tackle poverty
far better than existing ones and the
second thing this is very clear to me is
that not using the right models is not
the biggest problem here the biggest
problem is that there is a huge
reluctance to acknowledge that any
change in approach is needed after 10
years of austerity that hit women
disproportionately
why are we still not talking about the
fact that rising poverty levels and
inequality is deeply rooted in women's
inequality and that solving women's
inequality would make life better for
everyone with all the work that the
World Bank and the United Nations are
doing to tackle poverty and as it
repeatedly throws up data showing that
women experience it disproportionately
why are we still not prioritizing
women's equality as the route to ending
poverty before I did this job as a funny
sort of job I feels odd describing as a
job but before I did this job I used to
work for Reuters news agency and I
worked there for about 20 years and I
covered everything from stock markets to
currency markets to oil markets
economics to politics to trade
technology diplomacy Foreign Affairs I
did all sorts of stuff and the first
thing I noticed most quickly of all as a
rookie reporter although it was
subsequently borne out by years of
financial reporting and editing was how
quickly investors move when there's a
chance of making money on the next big
thing it basically all comes down to
fear and greed and all it would take
would be one report from one of the big
investment banks or the professional
services organizations and whoosh they'd
be off there'd be a stampede either the
rush at the rush to buy rubles
Horo those days the technology bubble at
the endless ups and downs of the oil
price the stampede to Brazil the
Stampede to China by stark contrast a
raft of analyses from Price Waterhouse
Cooper to Grant Thornton to McKinsey to
Barclays to the EIB all showing that
women's equality could add billions to
companies to countries GDP
and company's profits was met by deadly
silence tumbleweed we have ignored women
for so long that even when their
experience is shown to be at the heart
of the biggest problems confronting
modern society we will look away from an
effective resolution rather than look
directly at women we have to see women
and to do that we have to stop seeing
them as a special interest group a
subsection of real life a thinner
version of the male experience the
reason we set up the women's equality
party was to show first of all that
solving inequality requires women
specific policies and then also to show
that it is actually possible to design
for women in a way that benefits
everyone
that embracing difference benefits
everyone that exposing the flaws of
existing designs is necessary for the
advancement of all in society that
putting the furthest first because the
poorest and the most marginalized are
always women forces us to go beyond the
limitations of the current binary
socialism or conservatism that feminism
is a political ideology in and of itself
we have to challenge the idea that
feminism belongs to all the other
parties to claim as they see fit as a
secondary consideration to more
important things and in particular we
have to challenge ideas about identity
politics about whose identities we are
considering in current politics
now you see by that such a little ripple
that went through there really is
nothing so derided in the marketplace of
political ideas as identity politics it
is a term that immediately conjures a
cult of the humorless arbiters of
offense we shut down imaginative debate
in the name of esoteric special
interests this powerful narrative is
rooted even in the dictionary definition
of identity politics which goes a
tendency for people of a particular
religion race social background etc to
form exclusive political alliances
moving away from traditional broad-based
party politics and I think it's
astonishing that anyone still thinks
politics is broadly for everyone
particularly in the age of Trump and
Farage and their assault on the liberal
elite for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of arson ideas at IAI TV
you